it's really important for me not to be
hyperbolic in this segment because this
is so serious but to accurately
communicate to you the dire situation
that we're in with regard to the 2020
election the language might sound like
what is normally hyperbolic language but
in this case it just accurately reflects
the circumstances what I'm talking about
is that the 2020 election is not going
to be a fair election in what we most of
us imagine when we say a fair election
if a Democrat is to defeat Donald Trump
in 2020 it's going to be despite all
sorts of underhanded tactics and endless
betrayals of the type of election that
our founding fathers wanted us to have
year in and year out foreign
interference happened in 2016
Trump just said to George Stephanopoulos
on national TV that he'd welcome help
again in 2020 Republicans including
Mitch McConnell are simply blocking any
bill to secure the election from foreign
interference which we've talked about
the big voting machine lobbyists are now
donating to Mitch McConnell's campaign
which we've talked about voter
suppression not voter fraud remember
voter suppression which is this package
of policies that Republicans have been
pushing for decades to limit voting
hours to limit voting locations in
poorer non-white democratic-leaning
areas combined with using the boogeyman
of voter fraud as a sort of straw man to
justify voter purges and voter ID laws
and so much more
gerrymandering which already favors
Republicans because of the urban-rural
divide just systemically but is used
even more grossly to favor Republicans
and how the congressional districts are
currently drawn the very real
possibility that Donald Trump if at any
point he truly starts to believe that he
is losing rather than writing off all
the polls is fake panics and tries to
get us into a military conflict that
could be Iran could be Venezuela could
be I mean almost anything with this guy
that does affect voters and it will be
another thing that Democrats and whoever
is the eventual Democratic nominee
is going to need to overcome so what I
want to convey to you today is that even
if we deal with any three of these four
major ways in which this is not going to
be a fair election it is going to be an
uphill battle where the Democratic
nominee whoever he or she ultimately is
is going to need to overcome significant
slanting in the infrastructure of this
election in order to actually win now
that doesn't mean that it's impossible
but what you need to do is immediately
put out of your mind the idea that it
might be a fair election because it's
just not going to be okay there's a
Rolling Stone article pointing out that
Republicans are more than willing to
help make this an unfair election so if
you are even considering like for a
split second not voting because of all
of these things you should rethink that
okay if you say the election is
fundamentally slanted towards donald
trump's reelection so i'm not going to
vote that is the exact wrong reaction to
be having you need to vote because your
vote is so much more important given
that this is going to require if the
Democratic candidate is going to win
going above and beyond all of these
systemic factors that have the playing
field slanted in the direction of Donald
Trump the last midterm okay the 2018
midterms that also was not a fair
election Democrats were able to pick up
record seats in the house because people
voted in such numbers that we were
stronger than the lack of fairness that
is implicit in the system in a way that
tilts towards Republicans in the ways
that I described so you need to realize
that we're fighting people who don't
care about fairness okay the Republican
Party decided decades ago that they
don't care about being fair or behaving
appropriately or running elections in a
way that is in line with what the
founding fathers wanted this is
basically sport to them okay it's just
wins and losses that's all it is it's
strikes and balls or whatever all that
matters is wins on the board if the
policies destroy farmers in the Midwest
if they destroy democracy at its core
whatever if they destroy the middle
class as long as this republican party
sees that they are quote winning and
checking off the right boxes on the
scoreboard that is all that they care
about so on the one hand we can't stoop
to their level because we are not like
them but if we don't start winning
somehow we will never take them out of
power and that's what the Left needs to
understand and that's why a lot of my
focus lately has been on trying to unite
the left rather than allowing these
arbitrary and rigid divisions of the
left to fracture the left because we're
up against significant unfairness in
this upcoming election so if you don't
vote we don't even have a chance even if
you do we still need to overcome all the
injustice of the system that they've
successfully put in place over the last
several decades for their own gain at
their own for their own advantage
so that should I hope motivate you to
vote rather than say them not even going
to bother if you disagree with my take
on this I want to hear from you if you
think that this scenario means you
shouldn't even bother voting I vehement
ly disagree with you and I hope you'll
call in later this week when I take live
calls and confront me about it because
it's something I absolutely want to talk
to you about because it is so important
it is I I don't want to be hyperbolic
but the reality is extreme and we need
to understand that